there is another process that we need to
review before we launch into the world
of dreams and that is the difference
between a symbol and a sign and how to
expand or amplify a symbol what exactly
is a sign and how does it differ from a
symbol well a sign is something with a
fixed meaning this meaning is culturally
or universally understood even though
there may be slight variations across
cultures an example of a sign is the
octagonal red sign we use to indicate a
stop in traffic the stop sign has only
one meaning that of bring your vehicle
to a complete halt just before this red
sign it doesn't mean drive through yield
or buy a hamburger or fries and pretty
much all cultures the same sign the stop
sign is used to mean the same thing stop
another sign would be the red exit sign
that we see above a door in a movie
theater or an office this has only one
meaning that of leave this place by
going through the door under the sign it
doesn't mean anything else
it is often red in color so that we can
all see it in an emergency and most if
not all of us know that in an emergency
you need to access exit at this place so
a sign is some word a shape or an object
that has a single fixed meaning now here
is where we run into some difficulties
when we speak of symbols and signs those
of you that have some knowledge of
classical Freudian psychoanalysis will
know that many of the objects that Freud
interpreted in dreams say hills or
tunnels or apples or bananas were
referred to in a way that made them
signs the Apple equals the female
breasts in Freudian dream interpretation
or the banana means the male penis one
sign has one meaning so it is quite
incorrect from a Union perspective to
interpret dream imagery in affixed ways
from this perspective stay away from
those dreadful dream dictionaries you
find in bookstores that tell you if you
dreamt of an Apple it means a breast or
any other such fixed meaning these books
should be called dream sign dictionaries
and not dream symbol dictionaries well
then if this is the case for signs
having fixed meanings how do they differ
from symbols a crucial difference is
that a symbol does not have a fixed
singular meaning young in dealing with
the difference between a freudian sign
interpretation and his own simple
interpretation said the following and I
quote the true symbol differs
essentially from this and should be
understood as an intuitive idea that
cannot yet be formulated in any other or
better way end quote and that's from
collected works 15 paragraph 105 better
still young also said and I quote a
symbol always presupposes that the
chosen expression is the best possible
description or formulation of a
relatively unknown fact which is
nonetheless known to exist or is
postulated as existing end quote
as from collected work 6 paragraph 8 1 4
but this leaves us in some difficulty
how then do we know what a symbol means
what if I get it wrong and say it means
something completely different from
someone else
well in this situation you are quite
safe because you know what a symbol
means to you better than anyone else
because you get a meaning about a symbol
from
own unconscious your own feelings and
your own experiences let's take a simple
example say you dreamt of a horse you
told your dream to a friend and then
began to explain the meaning of the
horse in other words you began to
enlarge on the meaning of the symbol as
a child you may have been thrown from a
horse and broken your arm and never
ridden one since you may dislike and
fear horses as a result and find the
appearance of a horse symbol in your
dream to be scary and threatening so the
meaning of the horse symbol to you is
very negative your friend on the other
hand may have been raised on a cattle
ranch and spent many hours of his
childhood on the back of a horse
rounding up cattle he may have had a
favorite horse that he trained and rode
for the years he spent at home on the
ranch to him the horse is a solid
powerful dependable creature that helped
do his ranch chores was his good friend
and helped him get through some
difficult terrain or times the horse
symbol for him is one of a positive
loyal dependable friend this is quite
different to your meaning of the horse
so which one is wrong in the meaning of
the horse symbol you or your rancher
friend the answer is neither you are
both absolutely correct
as you are developing a sense of the
meaning of the horse symbol from your
actual lived experience yours of being
bucked off the back of the horse and his
from having a horse as a working animal
on the ranch so you can see how the
meaning of a symbol becomes accurate
largely from your own experience well
what do we do with those dream symbol
dictionaries then I'm not sure what you
have done with yours but mine sit on the
bottom of my bookshelf and I turn to
them
only when I need to find the more
Universal aspects of a symbols meaning
you are the best symbol dictionary in
the world as you rely on your own psyche
to provide the meaning but this isn't
where it all ends as all we have really
done is to develop our personal
associations to the symbol from these
associations we do need to enlarge a
symbol by tapping into the universal
nature of the symbol meaning that as
symbols are such powerful images and
exist in the collective unconscious we
need to see how different cultures
attribute meaning to a universal symbol
this means that the core meaning of a
symbol is the same across cultures but
each culture will add something specific
to its own cultural meaning of a symbol
and it's here that we need to dust off
those symbol dictionaries in our
bookshelves and do some research so can
you see how massively different a symbol
and a sign are